hey Mary here once again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week PC players can play the
dance dance revolution of death that is
kickbeat originally on Vita and ps3
kickbeat karate kicks its way to PC so
you can take a solid chunk out of bad
guys kick some serious beat january
twentieth also this week you can bust
out your ad nollie big spin flip 180 in
olly olly coming out this week for
PlayStation Vita the developers wanted
to create a skateboarding game we're
landing and Ollie actually took some
effort none of that grinding on a rail
for ten minutes without stumbling like
in a Tony hot game this one's more
realistic
Wow grind it up January 21st also this
week insurgency makes its way to steam
early access but if you're all like i
only pay money for finished games then
don't worry because the game comes out
january 22nd the intense close quarters
combat forces players to work together
to secure crucial strongholds so you
gotta ride together die together bad
boys for life gonna do what you gonna do
when we come for you if you don't want
to wait you don't have to it's available
for early access now and finally there's
also an RPG called a wizard's lizard
coming out that looks pretty cool and
that's pretty much it this week folks
what if you want more games maybe you
should develop some January's a slow
month what do you want for further
details visit gamespot's new releases
page release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change see
you next week